[Music]
all right sports now while the golden
knights are preparing for game one of
the western conference semifinals
tonight
the canucks are tough test but now vegas
is also trying to defeat defeat
distractions
john treach has our story john that's
right for the first time in the history
of las vegas pro sports we have a
playing time controversy
coach pete deboer is going with
goaltender robin leonard over future
hall of famer mark andre fleury
the decision has stirred strong emotions
and now everyone is trying to avoid a
crisis
in the crease the board played leonard
in four of the five first round games
altogether the mid-season acquisition is
five and one in the postseason flurry is
2-0 and was
spectacular in game three against the
blackhawks but the decision to go with
leonard moving forward clearly did not
sit well with the flurry camp
the three-time cup winners agent alan
walsh released this highly detailed
picture
yesterday on twitter the proverbial
knife in the back is inscribed with the
boar's name
the golden knights called the 9 30 a.m
game day press conference where fleury
tried to fan the flames of frustration
and elaborate on the intentions of his
agent i think he
was maybe a way to defend defend me into
that situation
you know for not playing much but um
you know i'm i'm here to uh to win with
my team and
um it's a success you know and that's
that's what matters and
um you know so because of that i
asked him to take a picture down and
eat it this morning fleury did not deny
knowing his agent was going to post this
but he also says that he talked to robin
leonard and pete deboer
on saturday and there are no hard
feelings